en las últimas 24 horas algunos países
de europa están teniendo rebrotes
francia que anunciaba hace apenas 24
horas nuevas medidas registró más de
6.000 casos nuevos y se está acercando
en proporciones a su primer pico el 30
de marzo pasado llegó a haber siete mil
578 casos nuevos la curva francesa es
ascendente y podría presentarse una
segunda ola
hago un llamado a una coordinación
europea y creo que lo importante y eso
es lo que francia propuso a nivel
europeo y debemos tratar de lograr en
los próximos días es no repetir los
errores de marzo limónov de onís uno de
los buenos alumnos es alemán ya se
notificaron unos 1500 casos en las
últimas 24 horas una tasa relativamente
baja a comparación de sus vecinos
alemania alcanzó su pico en el 28 de
marzo con 6 mil 294 casos nuevos pero la
evolución de la curva parece controlada
desde hace más de seis meses el
coronavirus ha determinado mi trabajo
como canciller
de la perspectiva de hoy me parece
bastante claro que esto seguirá siendo
así en el invierno y el otoño es
probable que los próximos meses sean aún
más difíciles que en el verano 7 la
situación más crítica está en españa el
país rodea los 10.000 casos nuevos la
última vez que españa alcanzó esas
cifras fue el 26 de marzo pero no
podemos permitir que la pandemia vuelva
a adueñarse de nuestra vida como lo hizo
desgraciadamente en primavera y quiero
ser claro en este punto no lo vamos a
permitir
repito no lo vamos a permitir con 35
millones de casos
europa es la tercera zona geográfica más
impactada detrás de américa y así